Macron et le candidat de la
mondialisation sauvage de lubérisation
de la précarité de la brutalité sociale
de la guerre de tous contre tous de du
saccage économique notamment de nos
grands groupes du dépeçage de la France
par les grands intérêts économiques du
communautarisme et tout cela piloté par
Monsieur Hollande qui est à la manœuvre
maintenant de la manière la plus claire
qui soit monsieur Cazeneuve a même dit
je crois que c'est hier ou avant-hier
faites voter dimanche résolument pour
Emmanuel Macron faites-le avec la fierté
de ce que nous avons accompli et le
désir de voir ce que nous avons accompli
se poursuivre bon et bien moi face à
cela je suis la candidate du peuple je
suis la candidate de la France quelques
nous l'aimons de sa culture de sa
civilisation de son unité je suis la
candidate de la nation qui protège qui
protège nos emplois qui protègent la
sécurité de nos compatriotes qui
protègent nos frontières qui nous
protège face à la concurrence
international déloyal et face à la
montée en puissance du fondamentalisme
islamiste et puis somme toute les
Français ont aussi pu voir le vrai
Macron dans cette ce second tour la
bienveillance a fait place à la
médisance
la stratégie marketing a été reprise en
main par la machine du PS et puis le
sourire étudié se transforme en ruptus
au fur et à mesure des meetings l'enfant
chéri du système et des élites en
réalité à tomber le masque monsieur
Macron voilà c'est bien je trouve que
c'est
utile on a vu les choix que vous avez
fait dans ce second tour des choix qui
sont des choix cyniques d'utilisation
d'arguments de campagne qui sont honteux
et qui révèlent peut-être la froideur du
banquier d'affaires que vous n'avez
probablement jamais cessé d'être donc je
pense que cette période en réalité de
clarification a été profondément
utile aux Français pour faire un choix
c'est donc à vous et Macron de me donner
votre état d'esprit à quelques jours du
crétins bah écoutez vous avez démontré
que vous n'êtes en tout cas pas la
candidate de l'esprit de Funès de la
volonté d'un débat démocratique
équilibré ouvert merci pour cette belle
démonstration que vous venez de faire
Madame Le Pen je ne m'attendais pas à
autre chose moi je vais pas vous dire
que vous êtes la véritable héritière non
seulement d'un nom d'un parti politique
du parti politique de l'extrême droite
française de tous un système qui
prospère sur la colère des Français
depuis tant et tant d'années je ne vais
pas vous dire que vous revendiquez même
cet héritage puisque vous l'avez porté
depuis que vous avez repris ce parti et
que depuis 40 ans dans ce pays nous
avons des Le Pen qui sont candidats à
l'élection présidentielle parce que ça
ne m'intéresse pas alors vous allez
continuer votre logorrhée puisque c'est
ce que vous faites à longueur de
rassemblement et autres Madame Le Pen ce
qui est extraordinaire c'est que votre
stratégie mais c'est normal ça fait des
décennies que ça dure votre stratégie
c'est simplement de dire beaucoup de
mensonges et de dire tout ce qui ne va
pas dans le pays mais vous ne proposez
rien parce que si vous aviez suivi le
film des dernières années les charges
ont baissé le cice c'est une baisse de
charge des grandes que je propose non le
cice c'est pour toutes les entreprises
c'est pour ça que dans le projet que je
porte je propose de baisser de 6 points
les charges des tpepm c'est pour ça que
je propose de baisser l'impôt sur les
sociétés 25%. vous ne proposez rien
toutes les entrées monsieur Macron vous
êtes mais non mais moi je moi je donne
une priorité totale au TPE mais je pense
que ce sont les crée l'emploi vous ne
proposez rien vous êtes simplement vous
faisez une fois de plus la vie des
grands groupes
dans la situation buvez des coups à la
retendre Madame Le Pen les Français et
les Françaises ils méritent mieux que
cela je vous assure la vérité il souffre
il mérite oui il méritent d'abord la
vérité puisque les insinuations parce
que si vous étiez bien renseigné sur
tous les cas industriels que vous avez
cité vous seriez que c'est très
différent je n'étais pas ministre quant
à SFR a été vendu et SFR était la
propriété d'un groupe totalement privé
qui était vivant non je n'étais pas
ministre Madame Le Pen SFR était la
propriété d'un groupe privé qui
s'appelle Vivendi nous sommes dans un
état où la propriété privée respectée
c'est le groupe Vivendi qu'il a vendu ne
dites pas de bêtises vous en dites
beaucoup ça n'est qu'une des bêtises que
vous avez préféré depuis tout à l'heure
mais surtout ça ne fait pas avancer le
pays mes sœurs il voulait pas le vendre
mais personne ne voulait la vendre
simplement quand vous avez un groupe
privé qui est détenu par des capitaux
privés oui chercher dans vos dossiers
vous seriez bien
et vous allez voir que vous allez être
en difficulté une fois de plus je
connais je connais un peu les dossiers
60 ans quand ils ont 40 années votre
élection si vous êtes élus non je
m'engage à ce que ce soit le cas d'ici
la fin du quinquennat pour une raison
simple non non ça a pas changé
dans les deux mois oui vous aviez l'idée
que je suis élu et là vous avez d'un
seul coup changé excusez-moi mais parler
de vos projets mais pas du bien parce
que forcément vous le connaissez mal
alors inspirez-vous je précède pour
vous-même très clairement le plus vite
sera le mieux le plus vite sur le mieux
parce que l'idée qu'on demande toujours
des sacrifices aux Français en toute
circonstances en leur expliquant et on
les culpabilisant d'ailleurs c'est votre
grande spécialité objectivement si notre
régime de retraite ne fonctionne pas
c'est à cause d'eux c'est parce qu'il
travaille pas assez longtemps c'est
parce que il ne travaille pas assez il y
a toujours un phénomène de
culpabilisation des Français en toute
circonstance et d'ailleurs s'ils sont au
chômage monsieur Macron vous leur dites
c'est de votre faute c'est parce que
vous acceptez pas les offres qui vous
sont faites et c'est la raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs vous voulez
supprimer en réalité limiter
l'indemnisation du chômage en expliquant
que et bien on leur fera deux offres on
sait pas où on sait pas de quoi ça se
trouve à 200 km ou à 300 km de parler de
votre projet et si au bout de deux fois
et si au bout de deux fois ils disent
NON et bien ils n'auront plus
d'indemnisation chômage et bien moi
cette culpabilisation des Français je ne
la supporte plus les Français n'ont
aucune raison de culpabiliser totalement
raison si notre système mais ils ont le
droit qu'on les prenne pas pour des
imbéciles non plus on peut terminer oui
mais allez-y mais parler de votre projet
comme vous le disiez voilà contre le
terrorisme il faut d'abord retrouver nos
frontières nationales tout de suite
immédiatement et ça ce sera quelque
chose que je ferais immédiatement après
mon arrivée au pouvoir il faut que l'on
expulse tout de suite les fichiers
étrangers qui sont sur notre territoire
tous ceux qui étranger sur notre
territoire antalien qui est
fondamentalisme islamistes d'or dors
tous ceux qui sont double nationaux
double nationaux on mettra en œuvre la
déchéance nationale je sais que vous
êtes contre cela mais vous êtes pour
toutes les propositions de laxiste et
contre toutes celles qui font preuve de
fermeté mon projet
déchu de leur nationalité ils seront
également pour ceux qui font sauter
terrorisés dans la déchéance qui est un
débat qui a déjà eu lieu le président de
la République a voulu le faire ça règle
rien au sujet mais c'est tout continuer
quelqu'un qui se fait sauter puisque
aujourd'hui les terroristes que nous
devons combattre et que Gérald créer ce
sont des gens qui se suicident dans les
attentats on l'a vu vous pensez vous
attendez l'attentat à vous
moi j'attends pas l'attentat simplement
quelqu'un qui est dans ses dispositions
d'esprit la déchéance de nationalité
brandie par Madame Le Pen vous pensez
que ça le fait trembler il faut aller
beaucoup plus au cœur beaucoup plus au
fond et beaucoup plus concret pas des
principes alors pas de leçon en effet
donc avant avant qu'ils aient commis
l'attentat c'est avant tes chances de
nationalité expulsion immédiate voilà
déjà tout cela ils sont plus sur le
territoire et donc nos policiers et les
gendarmes peuvent continuer à surveiller
un nombre qui soit limité de personnes
parce que arrivé quand même à laisser
sur le territoire monsieur Macron 11000
fichiers pour fondamentalisme islamiste
11000 ça c'est aussi le bilan de votre
gouvernement c'est une véritable honte
le lendemain de l'attentat
vous avez dit je vais pas inventer quand
même un programme dans la nuit contre le
terrorisme c'est à dire que vous vous
présentez à l'élection présidentielle
comme vous dans le piège des sauts de
Cabris mais non puisque vous a
constamment vous êtes dans la victime
parler je ne suis pas du tout énervé
Madame Le Pen regardez je suis en train
de jouer du retard sur vous allez le
rattraper alors laissez-moi parler de
votre projet ne dites pas de bêtises sur
le mien j'ai un projet mais simplement
on a une réagit pas aux événements comme
vous n'avez pas de projet je les
anticipe non seulement vous n'avez pas
de projet mais en plus vous avez une
complaisance pour le fondamentalisme
islamiste c'est ça peut-être le
développer vos propositions
à peu près je vous sens un peu agacé
là d'un système d'un parti d'un nom moi
je ne suis pas l'héritier ce
gouvernement j'y ai participé s'il vous
plaît je n'étais pas d'accord et j'en
suis sorti j'ai démissionné j'ai quitté
le gouvernement la fonction publique
donc vous pouvez me renvoyer constamment
à tout ce qui a été fait durant les cinq
les dix les 15 dernières années je
répondrai de tout ce que j'ai fait moi
je ne répondrai s'il vous plaît vous
êtes l'héritier de Français qui vous
soutient deux fois par jour ainsi que de
l'intégralité de vos amis ministres avec
lesquels vous avez gouverné
des ministres socialistes qui ont été
vos collègues au gouvernement l'émission
au début de l'émission C'est héritage
tellement évident
je sais d'où je viens d'international
quand même ça
qui ne veut pas vous croire en fait les
Français les Français ne sont pas aussi
bêtes
[Applaudissements]
au gouvernement mais non vous êtes
partis pour pouvoir organiser votre
candidature celle du système s'il vous
plaît mettre en place les conditions
pour faire croire en français que
justement vous étiez on va parler que
vous étiez
choisi
par les socialiste et par le schiste
on sort ou pas de l'euro
il faut retrouver notre lien au front ou
pas il faut retrouver notre monnaie
nationale donc on revient en France
c'est essentiel d'accord essentiel
essentiel on vous proposez bien de
sortir de l'euro non je vais renégocier
pour que l'euro on sent libère et on le
transforme en monnaie commune c'est ce
qu'il a c'est ce qu'il a il était avant
qu'il devienne la monnaie de la France
avec de l'Euro
avec de l'euro
les banques centrales pairont avec de
l'euro si elles le souhaitent les
grandes entreprises paieront avec le
rôle si elle le souhaite vous le savez
très bien ça
pas pour les Français pas pour les
particuliers pas pour les petites
entreprises et vous savez très bien mais
c'est quoi servira
de
de monnaie vous le savez encore une fois
ça existait
juste avant l'Euro juste avant que
l'euro devienne notre monnaie physique
en France et oui et oui et oui et oui
c'était l'euro déjà et avant donc les
grandes entreprises elles payaient en
euros en écurie de 93 à 2002 toutes les
entreprises pouvaient payer les grandes
entreprises pouvaient payer
effectivement en euros ce système a
parfaitement fonctionné monsieur Macron
ne faites pas semblant de ne pas le
savoir vous le savez très bien il a
fonctionné dans le cas du SMS et
honnêtement de 93 à 2002 c'était plutôt
performant mais ce qu'il faut que les
Français comprennent surtout c'est que à
la limite ça les regarde même pas cette
Romanée commune c'est une monnaie une
facilité entre les États c'est une
facilité pour les banques centrales mais
ça ne les touche pas et les grands et
maintenant eux ils auront une monnaie
mais les extras
à personne vous êtes à plat ventre en
permanence devant l'Allemagne devant
syndicats magistrature devant lui F
devant les communautaristes devant les
puissances d'argent entre différents
je suis debout mais pour être debout je
n'ai pas besoin de salir vous en
permanence vous salissez représentez les
étrangers vous salissez les juges comme
on vient de le voir vous salissez les
uns et les autres Madame Le Pen notre
pays n'a pas besoin de ça il a besoin
d'apaisement et d'efficacité je le
regrette je le regrette je voulais dire
c'est triste vous voulez dire les
ouvrières de garde que vous avez traité
dit les traits vous voulez dire les
chômeurs que vous avez envoyé acheter un
costard vous voulez dire les habitants
du Nord que vous avez traité
d'alcoolique les harkis et les rapatriés
du Nord ils avaient crier du traité de
criminels aller leur parler je suis allé
les voir chacun de tout ça c'est ce que
vous voyez les 9 millions et d'ailleurs
les 9 millions d'électeurs les miens et
ceux de Nicolas Dupont-Aignan que vous
avez tenté de salir pendant tout ce
second tour
injurieux les Français et les Français
qui ont voté pour vous comme pour
Monsieur Dupont-Aignan je les ai
toujours respectés je n'ai jamais fait
de leçon de morale mais je les connais
aussi ils viennent j'en ai dans ma vie
dans ma région je dis juste vous dire
une chose regardez ils sont là ils sont
dans les campagnes dans les villes je
parlais de votre réseau sociaux je parle
du parti de l'extrême envahisseurs celui
que vous dirigez le parti de l'extrême
droite qui dit des mensonges sur les
réseaux sociaux qui poussent à la haine
qui me laisse des journalistes qui
prodiguent partout un traitement la
grande brutalité mais oui madame Le Pen
regardez cette campagne celle que vous
avez fait vivre qui est venu à plusieurs
reprises devant mes rassemblements
publics menacés et frappés je l'ai vécu
Madame Le Pen c'est la vérité
[Musique]